what i'd like to do in this video is
order these six numbers from least to
greatest so the least of them being on
the left-hand side and the greatest on
the right and i encourage you to pause
this video and see if you can do it on
your own before we work through it
together
so assuming you've had a go at it so
let's let's do it together and to help
us there let's plot these numbers on a
number line and i have a number line up
here so there you go there is a
handy number line and let's just take
them one by one so the first number here
we have seven thirds so let's see if we
can express that in a different way if
we can write that as a as a mixed number
so seven thirds how many how many holes
are here and the whole is going to be
three-thirds
so this is going to be let's see this is
going to be three-thirds
plus another three-thirds is going to
get us to six-thirds and so you're gonna
have one more third left
so this is seven-thirds three plus three
plus one is seven so this is three
thirds is one whole three thirds is one
whole so this is two and one third
so seven thirds same things as one two
and you see between consecutive integers
we have
we have these we have three spaces
so we are essentially marking off thirds
so two and one third is going to be one
third of the way between two and three
so it's going to be right over there so
that is
seven thirds
then we have negative five halves so
same logic negative let me do that green
color
so i can do it over here negative
five over two well that's the same thing
as the negative of 5 halves and 5 halves
is going to be 2 halves
plus another 2 halves
plus 1 half
so this is 2 and a half this is 1 this
is 1 and that's a half so this is going
to be so it's 1 plus
1 plus 1 half 2 and a half we have our
negative out there so it's negative 2
and one half
let's see negative 1 negative 2 and the
negative 2 and a half is going to be
halfway between negative 2 and negative
3. this is going to be right over there
so that is negative 5 over 2.
then we have 0 not too difficult it's
actually labeled on our number line for
us
then we have negative two
negative two once again on our number
line for us two
two steps two whole numbers to the left
of zero so negative two is going to put
us right over there
then we have negative 12 fourths so it
might jump out at you immediately 12
divided by 4 is 3 so this is going to be
the same thing as negative 3.
so this is
negative 12 4. or if you want to use the
type of logic that we used in these
first two numbers you could say
negative 12 over 4 is the same thing as
the negative of 12 fourths
which is four fourths plus another four
fourths so that gets us to eight fourths
plus another four fourths that's twelve
fourths this is one
two
and three or negative three
so negative three is the same thing as
negative twelve fourths and then finally
one more number negative three 3.25
so you could view this this is the same
thing negative 3.25
is the same thing as negative
3 and 25 hundredths
and 25 hundredths is the same thing as
one-fourth 25 is one-fourth of 100. so
this is the same thing as negative three
and one-fourth
so let's see let's go negative one
negative two negative three then we have
to go a fourth and we're not going to be
able to do it super precisely but it's
going to be less than a third so it's
going to be
right over there so that right over
there
is negative 3.25
so we wanted the numbers ordered from
least to greatest well we've done that
the least is negative 3.25
then negative 12 fourths then negative
five halves then negative two
then zero
then
seven thirds and we are done